when you worked with uh Daniel D Lewis
you play you play Lincoln son MH as an
actor he says he stays in character all
day long I don't know if that was hyped
for the movie or what no uh he was in
car he was linkoln all he was linkoln
when he wasn't Lincoln is that is that
weird I was so impressed and I think I
mean I don't know how you feel about his
work but I think he's he's sort of a
unique phenomenon it's brilliant the
[__] he does he's stays in the voice he
stays in the mood if you wanted to talk
to him it's not that you couldn't talk
to him but you weren't going to I wasn't
going to say like oh what what about
those Lakers I was going to be like look
at this painting that's on the wall or
something if we were going to talk cuz
you talking to Lincoln yeah to stay but
he show up in a horse and carriage when
he come to but but when I uh when I
arrived I received or I found a note
that he had written me on Old Paper with
a quill and ink wow and apparently in
penmanship that he had studied that is
similar to I mean he he obsesses for a
year before he does a role and he just
works the character for a year but when
you work with Spielberg yeah are you
sitting there almost studying Spielberg
more than you are even thinking about
your own role in the film because I
would imagine as a guy who wants to
direct yeah and now you're directing
your first film I would just sit there
and soak in whatever this motherfucker's
doing and I certainly did but and that's
also I think the best way to do your job
as an actor is to understand what the
director needs does he give you a lot of
Direction when you play Lincoln's Sun
he's actually what he was really good at
doing on Lincoln is taking the energy
that the actors are bringing and
figuring out okay I know how to capture
this and he can do it so deafly and and
again because Daniel is is playing with
with such sort of organic spontaneity
Stephen would have this uncanny ability
to be like oh you're going to do it that
way great cool give me one second I'm
going to set up this shot and he would
say Mr President can you please take a
step to the left and he'd set up a shot
call Daniel de Lewis Mr President he
called him Mr President yeah everyone
called him Mr
President come on does it sometimes just
get a little surreal for you like like
this is just a weird world surreal is a
great thing that's what I'm after what
do you think acting's about that's the
thrill of it is going into some other
place becoming some other
person